- Athletes do many of the
same things when they retire.
Gronk and his former
teammate, Julian Edelman,
recently had some fun with that.
So let's see it.
- We're retired athletes.
We're gonna get jobs on TV.
We're gonna tease a comeback.
- We're retired athletes.
We're gonna watch our old highlights.
We're gonna start a podcast.
(audience cheering)
- This should have been an "SNL" skit.
It's so funny.
They should do that
with musicians as well.
- We're retired athletes.
We go on "The Kelly Clarkson Show."
- There you go.
(audience cheering)
Good times, good times.
So wait, whose idea is that?
Are you into social media?
- A little bit.
- Okay.
- Yeah, social media's cool.
You gotta use it for the right reasons.
But I was at Julian Edelman's house,
he has a great podcast
called "Names with Games."
- Yeah.
- And we just did his podcast
and he has his whole
social media team there.
And then they showed me
this new trend on TikTok
and that was the new trend.
And they were like, "We're gonna do it
as retired athletes," and
it was such a great idea
and it came out so good.
- So funny.
I know, I was telling you on the break,
I was like, "That should
have been on 'SNL.'"
That would've been a really funny skit.
Yeah, so you have a new partner
for "Big Game Parties." Who is it?
- Yes, I actually do.
And Julian Edelman is
now a part of it as well.
And this is my second year
teaming up with Bounty.
And that's why I'm in my green suit
because I am the Bounty Man.
- Yeah.
- Yes, there's no doubt
about that.
- And green is a great color.
- And I'm from Buffalo,
so I know a thing or two about Buffalo.
Wings as well.
- Yeah, I love wings.
- You gotta always have
blue cheese on the side
when you're from Buffalo.
And you can't have football without wings.
And you can't have wings without Bounty.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- I can't have-
- Because it gets saucy,
it gets messy.
- [Both] The quicker picker upper.
- I just (smacks lips)...
- I got you.
- Cleans you right up.
- Quicker picker upper, I remember that.
No, I agree with all of that.
Except not the blue cheese.
I have to have ranch.
- Yeah!
(audience cheers)
- When you're from Buffalo...
- I'm Texan.
- When you're from Buffalo,
you use blue cheese only.
- When you're Texan you put ranch
or ketchup on everything.
- Yes.
But when you're from Buffalo,
you gotta have the buffalo blue cheese.
But if you're outside of Buffalo...
- Okay.
- I won't make the argument.
Yes, you can have ranch
'cause the buffalo blue cheese is the only
legit blue cheese out there.
- I like blue cheese.
I like blue cheese.
But there's something (smacks lips)
about ranch that I really love.
- Nope, blue cheese.
- Really, I just want the ranch.
- You gotta go with buffalo.
- And I just want it.
I need something, the
vessel for it to get there.
- Wait until you have
the buffalo blue cheese.
- Okay, I have had buffalo blue.
I like it, I like it.
And maybe when I'm in Buffalo-
- Where'd you go?
- I'll do that.
- Yes, when you're in buffalo.
- Everywhere else I say, "No."